Alright, this is one of the things I've
been wanting to teach you ever since we
started learning about design, and
this is about animating transitions.
It's easy to throw in
some Android L activity
transition animations to
spice up our application.
In Android 4.4, we added our transitions
framework but in Android L, we made it
easy to apply these transitions
when moving between activities.
As you can see clicking on
an item in our forecast list
causes custom animations to occur as
we transition into the next activity.
The toolbar at the top and
the bottom details move into place and
everything else fades.
Hitting the back key causes
a slightly different animation.
Just the bottom moves out,
and everything else fades.
This was done by first creating
a transition resource.
In this case, our transition resource
contains a transition set for
how we want our views to move.
We want all these animations
to play together for
a duration of a half a second.
We want everything to fade between
the views, except for the status bar and
the navigation bar.
If we don't specify a target in a
transition, it will apply to all views.
Exclude ID tells our fade
to apply to all views that
aren't in another transition.
Pretty handy.
We're going to have our
toolbars slide in from the top.
And the detail pane slides in
from the bottom and that's it.
We could do a lot more, but
too much animation can be distracting.
Now we still have to tell
Android how to apply the theme.
I'm going to add it to our custom theme.
We could specify it in code, but
I recommend doing it this way.
It's nice to be able to change
all of this from resources.
Note that we are both
applying themes here, and
setting a window flag to
enable content transitions.
Content transition must be enabled in
both the starting and ending activity.
And then we still have to write
a tiny amount of code to enable
a scene transition.
When we call start activity, we need
to give the system a special bundle.
Fortunately, ActivityCompat
will do the right thing for us.
And that's it.
See the instructor notes for
links to learn more about animations and
the transition framework.